Chimera is equipped with an array of structure
analysis resources that allow you to analyze the
protein environment around a ligand, visualize
interactions within the protein, and more.
Here we have the myoglobin structure 1mbo,
which contains a heme group as shown.
To analyze the protein environment
around this heme group,
we start by selecting it under the
non-standard residues category.
Now we can select all residues within the vicinity
of this heme group by going to Select by Zone.
In the Zone Parameters, we see that all atoms and
bonds within 5 ångströms of the current selection
will be selected. You can of course adjust these
parameters as needed. To fully include residues
that only fall partially into the 5 ångström
range, check this box here. Upon clicking OK,
the desired vicinity is selected. We can now
color this region by element by going to Actions,
Color, and By Element. And once we clear the
selection, we can see the coloration clearly.
We can also use Chimera's analysis resources
to measure the distance between two atoms,
such as the iron of heme and the coordinating
nitrogen of the proximal histidine residue.
To do this, we start by selecting both
atoms using Control, Shift, and left click.
Then under Tools, Structure Analysis, we
open up the Distances panel. When we click
Create, we see the distance displayed
in the panel and in the graphics window.
In addition to measuring distances,
you can also visualize hydrogen bonding
interactions within the structure. To do
this, go to Tools, Structure Analysis, and
Find H-Bond. If we apply the default settings, all
the hydrogen bonds within the structure are found.
To find all hydrogen bonds involving a specific
component, such as this serine hydroxyl, first
select your component of choice using Control and
left click, and then run the hydrogen bond search
again. Make sure to turn on this setting here to
restrict your search to the selected component.
Now only hydrogen bonds involving
the serine hydroxyl are shown.
Here we have the hemoglobin structure
4hhb. We can use Chimera to compare this
structure with the related myoglobin
structure that we have been analyzing.
To import the myoglobin structure, we go
to File, Fetch by ID, and type in: 1mbo.
The structure then enters the graphics window,
but it doesn't seem to be aligning with any of
the hemoglobin chains. To solve this problem,
we can go to Tools, Structure Comparison,
and select Matchmaker. Then we choose our
reference structure — the hemoglobin — and
the structure to match — the myoglobin. When we
click Apply, we see the myoglobin aligning with
chain D of the hemoglobin. With
hemoglobin chains A, B, and C deleted,
we can now get a better look at the overlay.
Although there are some positional differences,
such as the alpha helices, overall there is
much similarity between the two structures.
And as we see here, the positions of the key
histidine residues around the heme group are
well-conserved between the two structures,
as is the position of the heme group itself.